[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace go to squarespace.com
microcosmos to get a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
[Music]
domain we don't know how many rights of
Passage there are institutionalized
among amateur microscopists but we do
have to imagine that as people find
themselves navigating the microcosmos
for the first time they are often on the
lookout for tardigrades they funny
appearance and legendary resistance have
made tardigrades icons of the
microscopic world and who doesn't love
an icon recently our master of
microscopes James decided to try out a
new way to gather tardigrades the method
is simple and the results are quite
astounding all you need is some mesh
water and a little bit of
[Music]
patience
James has a little patch of moss next to
his trash bins so when he takes his
trash out he'll sometimes collect bits
of the Moss to look for microbes later
and we have seen igrit from these
bits of moss before the question is
though how to easily and efficiently get
the tardigrades to emerge from the Moss
so that James can watch them under the
microscope recently James was inspired
to try out something called the ban
funnel which he'd found in a book this
technique goes back to at least 1917
when it was first described by a Dutch
physician named Gustaf call Theodore
friedrick ban he invented the method
when he was in Java looking for
nematodes that live in soils
particularly parasitic hookworms and
since then the tool has become one of
several that nematode research use to
gather their research subjects in part
because it is just so easy to set up
here we can see just how simple James's
version is to make one of your own start
by placing some soil or moss on a mesh
fabric there's a number of things you
can use for the mesh including tea bags
a pair of tights or a
cheesecloth then place the mesh Moss
combination into a funnel and carefully
add water until only just part of the
Moss is dipped in the water make sure to
seal off the bottom of the funnel in
James's case he used a piece of rubber
tube the next day you can return to see
what organisms have gone through the
mesh and are now settled at the bottom
of the funnel the bman funnel has proven
to be a lasting tool for nematologists
to find worms buried in soil they begin
with the soil sample above the mesh and
with the addition of water the worms are
released from the soil this sets them
free to travel to the mesh and then
Through It ultimately settling at the
bottom of the funnel and after anywhere
from 16 to 72 hours the nematologist can
return to find a bundle of microscopic
worms at the bottom but this doesn't
necessarily work for all nematodes
nematodes that live in plants can take
longer to come out while other species
will travel away from the bottom of the
funnel so when James decided to try this
technique out to find tardigrade
there was no guarantee that it would
actually work he returned the day after
setting up his tardigrade trapping
apparatus and had to just hope for the
best he collected a drop of water from
the bottom of the funnel and prepared a
slide what he saw was incredible he
counted
196 tardigrades on his very first slide
that is a lot of
tardigrades if you tried the the Baran
funnel out and find that your
tardigrades are a bit hard to see
because bits of sediment or other things
floating in your sample don't worry
James had this same issue too they're
kind of hard to make out here because
there's just so much stuff for them to
hide in he just washed the tardigrades a
bit to make them a little more
presentable for us carefully pipetting
drops of water until there was minimal
debris to obscure our view and one of
the cool things about having caught so
many tardigrades at once is that you can
see how much variety there is to them
like here we have a few tardigrades that
look like giants crawling in a variety
pack of miniature tardigrades you can
also catch tardigrades in some funny
situations like this tardigrade that's
using its clawed feet to walk along the
glass slide tardigrades cannot swim but
they will use their claws to walk around
underwater and glass is a tough surface
for this one at the moment but over time
it will will get better though not
because of anything the glass or the
tardigrade does over time those little
dots of bacteria you see across the
screen will accumulate and as the number
of bacterias grow and spread across the
glass their bodies will create friction
along the surface which means the
tardigrade will be better equipped to
walk across it James also found this
tardigrade who looks trapped in a bag in
reality she's stuck to her cuticle which
is full of eggs that will one day hatch
and replenish the world of tardigrades
so the bman funnel helped James find a
ton of tardigrades without much fuss but
there's one major thing he did have to
keep in mind oxygen when he first added
the Moss to the funnel the tardigrades
were in their resting ton State their
entire being temporarily on Paw so they
could survive the desiccated conditions
and when James added water and created
more fa favorable conditions the
tardigrades emerged from the tons and
began walking around so ideally you will
give the tardigrades enough time to
unfreeze themselves but if you wait too
long then the water in the funnel begins
to form an oxygen gradient the surface
will have more oxygen while the bottom
will have less and that's a problem
because that bottom region is where all
the tardigrades end up settling as we
collect them through the mesh as more
and more tardigrades accumulate in that
bottom area they will have to compete
with each other for oxygen and sadly the
oxygen concentration can change very
rapidly killing the tardigrades before
they can return to their protective tons
but there are a few ways to prevent the
death of your tardigrades try to collect
the tardigrades from the funnel sooner
rather than later make take some trial
and error to find the right timing but
James says to try and avoid waiting
longer than a day and when James does
collect his tardigrades he provides them
with fresh water to replace the oxygen
deficient water they are living in he
also adds some algae from his pond
samples into the slides and keeps them
in transparent humidity Chambers under a
light source the light helps the algae
reproduce providing tardigrades with
both food and
oxygen these are the refinements that
James has made to the bman funnel to
make it work for his tardigrades and
depending on what materials you have
available to you and the samples you're
collect ing you might have to make your
own creative adaptations the joy of the
microcosmos is that it is all around us
but it can also take time and patience
to figure out the best ways to actually
find its inhabitants so we hope this
technique helps you all on your own
journey and if you do try the bman
funnel out on your hunt for nematodes or
tardigrades make sure to share what you
find with
[Music]
us thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
Squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create their website so whether you're
looking to create an online portfolio
start a blog or open an online store
Squarespace can help you out maybe it's
finally time to start that podcast
you've been thinking about well you can
use a Blog Page to publish and send a
podcast with Squarespace you can even
use your Squarespace blog to create an
RSS feed so listeners can use their
preferred podcast service to subscribe
and download a new episode and they make
it super simple to categorize schedule
and share those blog posts as well
Squarespace also makes it easy to keep
in touch with your listeners you can
interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded
comments and replies and generate extra
Revenue through membersonly content and
if you decide you want to start selling
some mer merch to go along with that
podcast Squarespace also is a powerful
e-commerce platform and you can even go
the extra mile and create thirdparty
extensions to help you manage inventory
streamline bookkeeping and ship products
across the world you can sign up today
for a free trial at squarespace.com and
when you're ready to launch visit
squarespace.com
microcosmos to get a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain the people on the screen right
now they are our patreon patrons they're
the people who make it all work here at
Journey to the microcosmos so that we
can continue finding new ways to
interact with our world and sharing
those ways with you I'm really excited
to see if anybody else goes ahead and
builds a Baran funnel to capture
hundreds of tardigrades if you want to
become one of these people you can do
that at
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
[Music]
nearby